Bob Saget the actor comedian he's on
tour he's staying with us here for a
little while I'm staying over fuller
house it wouldn't go away the show would
not 30 years later John Stamos really
wanted to make this show again I just
think he wanted to see me in pajamas and
but Stamos hasn't changed he looks the
same no he really looks good he he's
been injecting himself with his own
blood and and blood of baby hamsters but
he said okay like we look at athletes we
have a problem infantile a to use
performance-enhancing drugs but we would
have no problem with actors well he he
does not do that no but I'm saying
anybody like him in Hollywood if let's
say you were playing oh you assume half
of them are doing something yeah but
it's okay right yeah I mean I I take
lipitor admit it I take baby aspirin
which is bad cuz there's a lot of babies
with headache and I'm Robin shouldn't
take it don't take that it from a baby
there's a shorten you know ability to be
able to get this aspirin to these babies
because he you I am the reason yeah
there's a drought Bob is here he's also
got a book on the bestseller list New
York Times yes dirty daddy and the
fuller house shows is gonna get made I'm
doing three of them this season and I'm
on tour to do a new special that's why
I'm doing a lot of stand-up right now
because I want to do another hour
special to prove that I am a mature
caring person and it has a lot of comedy
music in it and things that would sue
though a woman to sleep and you have a
movie coming out there's a thing I'm
gonna direct and act in in September as
the
plans start date called Jake and so it's
just all the pieces are getting put
together you got to wait to all that
money's in the bank that's true you know
do you have the money do you have the
stuff do you have the money independent
films are hard to make when when you did
Entourage you know when I saw your
character I wondered if that's your
character because it didn't feel like it
was a character it felt like it was you
well that a compliment to you it is
actually because full house people don't
think oh my god why is Danny Tanner
cursing on this agent yo but I'm a combo
platter I'm actually working on
developing something right now and
writing something right now which is a
combo
four dimensions of a person rather than
just oh he's a dastardly guy on
Entourage and always a womanizer I had a
girlfriend once and had to put her down
but but she I was I said I'm not like my
entourage character she said look at
yourself and I was unshaven I was in the
jacuzzi I came out put on a black robe
I'm walking around with a beautiful
woman in a bikini a different woman
that's why we broke up but no I'm not
like I'm not that's a serious guy that
says foul things I actually do not talk
in my life to foul I just don't I'd save
it for the stage where it's safe but you
like being raw I like being real I like
being um I guess raw means I say
whatever I want to say but I but I care
about entertaining the people more than
I do in offending them my newer stuff I
mean I'm 60 right I don't want and I got
three daughters that are 29 26 and 23
which is also my locker combination so
if you want to see my jockstrap yeah you
can get in but um but I I don't
what are your daughters say like what I
don't let them speak where they went
you're embarrassing us then yes I did an
HBO special where I talked about my
middle daughter I said I called her the
center child not the middle because the
world revolved around her and I'm gonna
do that I'm gonna mention what I said
that upset her which serves no purpose
was at the time she kind of talked like
this oh my god I can't believe it daddy
you know typical kind of a la speak and
all she talked about was your cell phone
that's all 16 year olds talk about it oh
my god Verizon I love horizon and then I
said that she had a thong but was so
small that I was doing laundry I didn't
know what it was it looked more like an
eyepatch and he could floss with it all
kinds of terrible things and and she was
like dad I got so much crap for that for
for like a long time for like a year she
at school and she was only 16 at the
time so I I really feel bad about that
that I don't do anything hurtful about
anybody now I'm kind of talking more
about relationships and I lost my mom a
couple years ago and I'm I have a
amazing piece about what she was like
and her as she left that's like I
haven't
amazing piece that's nice to say it's in
my house yeah but but but can you make
fun of anything I don't like to do
religion in politics because there's so
many people to do it so proficiently I
try to keep everything below my belt
where it's safe I we are in such a world
where people are hurting so bad and
they're not really they're in a lot of
pain and if you turn on the news I mean
this is an entertainment show for all
intents and purposes and I hope it is it
is and that's what came here to tell you
okay thank you I'm like Clarence it's a
Wonderful Life yeah you're standing a
little too long that's all you're gonna
do Bob you've stayed a little too long
okay I've been told that many times but
I have staying power I've been told you
go you go Clarence and I'll go to Jimmy
Stewart okay okay okay so Dan if the
world did to have you these men wouldn't
be sitting here worshipping you Mary
Mary is that yo all right
that's the only thing comedian just got
his wings just now yeah I just I just
don't I don't try to tackle anything
that and I respect so much people that
are prophetic and what they do there are
so many comedians that I look up to and
I love and actually make I mean Louie
Louie and and Chris Rock and and
Chappelle and Bill burr I love Bill
burrows he's a good friend we've had
Bilborough in a couple he's just
fantastic and I love all comedians I
mean you know pretty much except for the
ones that are really kind of you know
when you hang out and say douchey on
here like fiduciary dude yes yes you can
when you when comedians hang around yeah
they don't they're not joking too much
but I would think there has to be a
little competition I don't hang the
people that are like that like bill and
I hang out and we'll smoke cigars and
they'll say I came up with this bit and
he'll talk about the bit and then we
kind of talk about what's going on in
the world on life and relationships and
and death and and and birth and Wow
that's why opening to Ben Casey nope not
one person watching knows what that is
remember do or you'll be the same age so
it's I believe the beginning of Ben
Casey was the doctor show the emergency
room life death yeah
infinity and beyond I was going to tell
you a story about my birthday I
celebrated you just helped new districts
to me and as 17th and I went to a Dodger
game with the great George Shapiro
Georgia Pierrot is a manager he's one of
the producers of Seinfeld he's still
Jerry's manager and he was 80 Kaufman's
manager just a wonderful sweet great man
and he asked me out of nowhere do you
want to go I said that's my birthday I'd
love to and his was yesterday and he's I
believe 85 and so I and he's a not the
tallest man in the world and people were
like balcony after picture and and and
he what he did was he pretended he
couldn't walk he turns a limp over like
I needed to help him like pop I'm sorry
I'm with my dad hi everybody
he hobbled all the way I want you to
stop yeah you do you don't want to say
no to kids some little kid comes over
goes we just signed my ball and I got
all excited and then this guy you know
the the police they're like yeah you
have to sit down you know cuz because
the guys hitting so poor kid everybody
thought I was a Sonny how do you stay in
character where he's acting like he's
your dad I was laughing at my crippled
father but my dad my dad's been gone for
10 years if I'd have brought my real dad
no one would have come near me because
he's been gone for 10 years nobody would
have hurt the Dodger dog business you
can see a Bob Saget Bob Saget calm for a
full tour dates fuller house and now the
Olsen twins wanted no part of this well
know what they want they did they have
such a big business as they're running
and they're not acting but they're still
invited to come and do it anytime in
play I'm actually gonna go to New York
this weekend and I'm not next to this
weekend and I'm in Irvine at the improv
mix that was a plug yeah well there's so
very sneaky really really subtle but
next week I will I will hopefully see
them in New York I did a play in New
York over November December January
called Handa Gardens another both
mary-kate and Ashley came to
see it we're very dear friends I love
them a lot and they're friends with my
daughters it's it's quite unusual that a
caste stays real friends I'm friends
with the in fact Stamos is throwing a
birthday party for me
in June coming up so that'll be pretty
exciting
I like that this birthday is not gonna
end yeah so a month later yeah throw
your party I can handle it
yeah Stamos has a really busy social
life so I gotta like work you in
he just please don't say it like that
that sounds wrong no but he's got a
month later for him he did what he wants
to make sure I'm not pregnant
and then we're waiting well it's not his
right who had a better run Stamos or
Derek Jeter uh I don't know I don't know
don't you guys serious here yeah because
I got yeah because Derek Jeter Derek
Jeter
yeah but stainless teemo's is never
going anywhere Stamos as an icon and
he's never gonna be you know an athlete
has its window I'm talking about with
the women Oh with the women no I can't
talk about that Stamos maybe Derek I
don't know you know what I don't know I
haven't counted snow loser I haven't
counted the notches yeah I haven't seen
the abacus over the headboard you're
gonna be in Connecticut in six weeks
yeah I'm and I in Ridgefield Connecticut
at some place it's like one of them
Richfield Playhouse yeah so far from us
can I come over your house would you
come to the show where you gonna be
there oh don't ask a quitter to CBS
don't ask a question for 60 we should
get some stuff together I would like
yeah I know the right problem the AARP
we got their card yeah I actually was a
cover of it like do you work
my bubbles this coffee said I got it's
great got any more chewy redox I can be
on got a pamphlet for the dead yeah yeah
I'd love to
that's very nice that you would and I
would love to I'll have my guy call your
guy yeah I assume you have a guy I saw
someone chained to a wall back no my
guys right over there paulie's my guy
yeah so Michael my we'll set it all up
here on TV I came here because I was
having a problem my directv bill and I
just stopped by
didn't realize they can monitor in here
and just be on the show yeah I could
quite a room like always looking for his
dead air yep
Bob thanks for the dead area Bob thanks
for stopping by
really yeah I've never been blow off
blowing off with so much amusement
bright I got caught up I always had a
triple slip just now yes you did you
stay Mose
god I want to see you in Richfield yeah
I can't wait I want to hold you a fuller
house he's got a movie Jake he's got a
book that's on the bestseller list it's
called dirty daddy he does it all and
then some and I will in the jacuzzi and
the jacuzzi
well you know what's bad about that if
you're in there too long it's like a dim
sum warmer it doesn't it doesn't you
can't have babies if you stay in there
too long that's one step to see we could
have stopped right there please say
thanks thanks Bob the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience